hello everyone today we're going to look
at the pimple
idiom in c plus plus and first we're
going to do a brief overview of what it
is
when to use it and then we're going to
show an example implementation and what
you might think it is is proof that
programmers don't care what you think
about their naming scheme but
it actually stands for pointer
to the implementation and it'll make
more sense shortly cppreference.com
has a pretty good description that we're
going to mainly go off of today all
right so let's just read the intro
together shall we pointer to
implementation or pimple
is a c plus programming technique
that removes implementation details of a
class from its object representation by
placing them in a separate class
accessed through an opaque pointer so if
that doesn't make sense that's okay
we'll soon here's a quick example we
have a class called a widget
it has a private member
well a struct that is a forward
declaration of the class
that is its implementation
uh there is instruct here you do
structure classes fine and then they
have
don't worry about this propagate cost we
are not going to be using that
it has a unique pointer
to that implementation
and then
in a cpp class we define that struct
now that is it in a nutshell but there's
more to it one of the great things it
does is it reduces your compile time
dependencies
and that'll make a little more sense
later but yes it can speed up
compilation if you're changing code okay
let's go over this explanation because
this is kind of the crutch of what it
does because private member datas of a
class participate in object
representation affecting size and layout
and because private member functions of
a class participate in overload
resolutions takes place before the
member access checking
any change to those implementation
details requires recompilation of all
users of the class
normally if you have
private data members and private stuff
in a class
if those change
anything that uses the class
has to
recompile however in this sort of setup
this is one of the advantages
if the implementation changes
then this is this cpp object is the only
thing that needs to recompile
anything else that is using your widget
does not need to recompile
so it can speed up
compilation times if you're just
changing the implementation details
all your other objects
in your project don't necessarily need
to recompile if they're using it
so you can get some faster compile times
that is the main thing the main
advantage
in my opinion
there's a few others which we'll see
pimple breaks this compilation
dependency
changes to the implementation do not
cause
compilation
consequently if the library uses
pimple as its abi
abi is application binary interface
newer versions of the library may change
their implementation while remaining
abi compatible
with other versions
all right let's talk about the abi for a
second so that all makes sense
in computer software an abi is an
application binary interface
it's an interface between two binary
program
modules
so it's basically the way two different
things talk to each other is the
simplest way to think of it alright
let's review the trade-offs the
alternatives to the pimple idiom are
well the inline implementation private
members and public members
are members of the same class or the
pure abstract class where the user
obtains a unique pointer to a
lightweight abstract base class the
implementation details
are in the derived class that overrides
its virtual member function also known
as the oop factory alright so they call
this feature of
it being separate a compilation firewall
in simple cases both pimple and factory
method break
compile time dependency between
implementation and the users of the
class interface
factory method creates a hidden
dependency on the v table
so reordering adding and removing
virtual member functions breaks the api
we haven't really talked about vtable
before
it's a virtual method table or virtual
function table a virtual call table a
dispatch table it's basically
um what your
your program's whole
front end of callable functions
and generally these don't contain the
definitions
they just contain like a lookup table
for everything available these are of
course specific to virtual functions
the pimple approach has no hidden
dependencies however if the
implementation class is a class template
specialization another thing we haven't
really talked about the compilation
firewall benefit is lost
the users of the interface must observe
the entire template definition
in order to instantiate the correct
specialization
a common design approach in this case
is to refactor the implementation in a
way that avoids parameters
parameterization
that's a mouthful of a word isn't it
this is another
use case the c plus plus core guidelines
don't over parameterize
we're not going to get too off topic on
the template specialization but just
know that if you've got template
specialization going on
you probably don't want to be using
this pimple idiom
all right just a few more things here
and then we'll get to the coding
we want to talk a little bit about the
runtime overhead there's an access
overhead
because
each call to a private men member
function
indirects through a pointer so as you
define your interface you're going to
have to go through a pointer to access
the implementation
for basically everything
this is
a pretty small overhead
and it is often
optimized away each access to a public
member made by the private member and
directs through a pointer
so as we're
designing the implementation you can
make a pointer back to the interface so
there is another end direction if you
need to access stuff in the interface
from the implementation both in
directions cross translation unit
boundaries
and so can only be optimized out by link
time optimization
another thing that might be confusing to
newer users but basically as you compile
separate objects
and they link together
later to make your final program there
is
unit boundaries and they cross them
using these pointers to each other so
sometimes that'll get optimized away and
become faster than you actually
programmed it by
your compiler and they do note here that
object oriented factory requires
interaction across translation units to
access both public data and
implementation details and offers even
fewer opportunities for the linked time
optimizer due to the virtual dispatch
okay space overhead adds a pointer to
the public component and if a private
member
needs access to a public member another
pointer is added to the implementation
or passed as a parameter to each call to
the private member that requires it this
is what i was talking about earlier
where you need a pointer back to the
implementation sometimes
lifetime management overhead
pimple and olfactory
place the implementation object on the
heap
and that can impose
significant run time overhead at
construction and destruction they may be
partially offset
by custom allocators since allocation
size for pimple is known at compile time
on the other hand pimple classes are
move friendly refactoring a large class
such as a pimple may improve performance
of algorithms that manipulate containers
holding such objects although moving
movable pimple has additional source of
run time overhead any public member
function that is permitted
on a moved from object and needs access
to private implementation incurs a null
pointer check
maintenance overhead
the use of pimple requires
a dedicated translation unit header only
libraries cannot use pimple introduces
an additional class a set of forwarding
functions and if allocators are used
exposes the implementation detail of the
allocator in the public interface
since virtual members are part of the
interface component of pimple
mocking a pimple applies mocking the
interface component alone a testable
pimple is designed
to allow full test coverage through the
available interface kind of important
i'm not sure if we'll get that far in
this episode and let's
talk a little bit about this
implementation
the object of the interface
type controls the lifetime of the object
and the pointer to the implementation is
usually a unique pointer
because unique pointer requires a
pointed type pointing to type is a
complete context in a context where the
leader is instantiated
special member must be user declared
and defined outlined in the
implementation file all right and they
talk about the propagate const we're not
going to worry about that a whole lot it
starts getting
experimental basically so we are going
to keep it a little more simple you
don't really need to worry about that a
lot but it is more advanced if you want
to try to figure it out
and understand it that's fine but i
wouldn't recommend it in the initial
understanding of pimple
just because i think it overcomplicates
it
all private data members and all private
non-virtual member functions are placed
in the implementation class all public
protected and virtual members remain in
the interface class if any of the
private members needs access to a public
or protected member a reference
or a pointer to the interface may be
passed to the private member function as
a parameter
alternatively back reference may be
maintained as part of the implementation
class
that'll make sense later
non-default allocators are intended to
be supported for the allocation of the
implementation object
any of the usual allocator awareness
patterns
may be utilized
including allocator template parameters
such as standard allocator and
constructor argument of
standard memory resource
all right and now
for an example our example is going to
start out a little like this and we're
going to talk all about it i made a poll
earlier this week and asked if you guys
wanted the next siblings tutorial
recorded on one windows or linux and you
guys pretty overwhelmingly voted linux
so we're going to be using
that to program up this pimple idiom and
test it out
i've also been informed that it's
pronounced like why canucks
alright welcome to my linux shell
where we are going to
use a gcc let's check the version
we're on 9.3
very nice
and we're going to make a pimple
implementation all right a nice clear
screen here
and the first thing i'm going to do is
change directory into my repos
and i'm going to make a directory
called
pim
and let's go ahead and make this a
little larger
so that you guys can read it
clear
and now we just want to make the basic
structure of our piece of software so
we're going to make a cmake file we're
going to use the touch command to do
that
c
make
lists dot text
and we're also going to make our main
files
we're gonna make our driver file to run
our stuff as a main.cpp
and we're gonna make a class
and we'll just call it uh
let me think of something here
oh why don't we stick with the whole
animal theme
so
we'll just call it an animal so we want
to make all those files
and now
uh i think i've done this wrong
i want to move all these
into the pimp folder
all right now let's go into the pimp
folder take a look and it's all there so
we just need to work these up
we're going to use visual studio code
because there's no way i'm doing this in
them we'll have several crashes
guaranteed if we try that all right
looking good let's see visual studio
code has notified me that
cmakelist.txt was not found on the root
folder how would you like to proceed i
would like to proceed with you getting
good because it is there it just doesn't
understand so let's just uh make some
basics he make stuff to get this
compiling because well we could just run
the gcc commands
but why not use cmake it makes it easier
and it makes it easier to expand later
we could optionally of course just use a
make file
but cmake is cmake's gonna make our make
file and
simplify all that
[Music]
so basically all we're gonna need here
is a minimum
version and we do have the cmake
extension here it's just cmake tools
i guess we have
a couple different things here
but it is kicking in and helping us
uh remember all these c mac see make
minimum required
uh version
we're just gonna go with
3.1 we could also go c make dash v oh
dash dash version then okay
3.16
so we could say 3.16
that's what we're using
but it's not super critical let's give
this project a name
we're just going to call it them
and we're going to add an executable
and we're going to say hey this
executable is the project name which is
some projects have multiple executables
and libraries and stuff in that case you
don't want to make your project name the
executable
but since we're just doing a single one
that's how we're gonna do it
and we're just gonna call this tutorial
that
oh we need to add on all the uh
all the files
which we can just click over here and
see
so we're gonna have a main dot cpp
and that should take care of the cmake
now we just need to program up these
files
uh let's make a quick int main and of
course we're going to include
animal dot h we'll be using that
and in this animal this is where we're
gonna make our whole
pointer to the implementation deal so
what are we gonna need here we're gonna
need
well of course the class well let's
start with the headers we're going to
need
memory
because of the unique pointer we plan on
using and basically we're just going to
use a class and we're going to call it
animal
and it's gonna have public and private
members
and the main thing here is we have
another class
called the implementation
um
this needs a name well
we're gonna stick with the very simple
name of impul and we might rename later
and basically here we're going to make a
unique pointer of it standard
unique
pointer
[Music]
and pull
and this unique pointer
needs a name and we'll just call it p
impl
all right and that's that's the core of
that but of course we're gonna need some
more things like
um constructors now this gets a little
this is where it kind of gets
interesting is with these constructors
because you need
several constructors well there's a few
kind of core things you need you need a
copy constructor
and that's going to be one that you
basically have to have publicly
available so we're going to make
animal
and we're going to make the const to
another animal by reference
and we're just going to call it
a
oh we don't want to define that here
though we'll define that in the
implementation
where we have access
to this thing
you know i don't actually think we need
the copy constructor we can even say
actually
specifically no copying this because
well it is a unique pointer
uh we don't want to copy it
let's spell animal correctly
however what we do want
uh i'll leave a little comment here
delete the copy
constructor i know it's built over on
but let's see we do want this one we
want
uh
now
double reference
and that
is going to be our move constructor
another thing we're going to need here
is we're going to need to define a
destructor now this is actually another
required thing
so
animal
destructor we'll define that shortly
[Music]
now we might also want just a default
constructor
and that's fine
you can even
have some constructors with parameters
we're not going to worry about that at
10 right now though
some other things that you probably want
here are
equals operator to do the move
so you can overload that by going uh
let's see animal
uh let's see
what's going to return so we're going to
return a reference to this animal and
operator
no not delete
equals and the name of the class
that way you can set one equal to
another via the move operation
or by constructing a new one
and since we're doing that we also want
to delete the copy version of this which
will be operator
[Music]
equals
and this one is going to be
const
animal
[Music]
by reference
but we're going to say
delete
all right so there we go
looking pretty good we're allowed to
move but we're not allowed to copy
now the base reason for this if i
understand this correctly
is because
well
if you're doing a move operation you're
essentially transferring ownership of
this unique pointer which is fine you
can transfer ownership
and essentially give it away but you
can't make additional copies of it
because well it's unique
that would be something more for like a
shared pointer
now of course we want some kind of
functions to actually operate on this
class so we're going to put those
up here somewhere
and these will use
the implementation
so let's make a void
um
what can animals do well
they should all be able to
eat
so we'll make an eat function
here
and maybe we'll uh
give it like an amount so like maybe
we'll just go with integer for now
and we'll call it
uh
a calorie
how many calories is it eating
uh we'll say
and
we don't need to make any private stuff
for this because that's going to be in
this implementation
and we'll make something
else we'll check fullness so we'll go
return an integer on this one
and we'll return
and we'll just call fullness
passing no parameters
but we're going to need access
to this and we're basically basically
going to return the fullness
so let's go ahead and design these few
functions
and
animal.cpp so in here
we'll include of course
animal.h
and we just need to make these functions
now so we're going to copy these
signatures put them over here
put animal in front of them
and give them a definition
but
they need some data to pull from and
that's where this implementation comes
in
this right here
so we need to define that and the way
it's defined
is like so
well it's animal and then it's symbol
and we need to be a class or a struct
we're going to go with class here you
can destruct if you want
it probably should be struck
and we just need to give it a definition
now this is private in the cpp file so
nothing else has access to it except for
this animal which is essentially an
interface at this point
so we're going to just make some
public members
and we're going to have
ins
um
fullness
now this is going to start out with some
default constructor
maybe 10.
so now
maybe we want this to be get fullness
sure let's do that let's put a get in
front of this
just to make it clear that's what we're
doing so now what this is going to do is
it's going to get this implementation
but it's going to get it through this
unique pointer here
also we need to work up our constructor
a little bit
and make sure we actually
instantiate this correctly
we'll do that in a second maybe i should
do that first
but it'll essentially be
uh making a unique pointer of
that there
well let's just do that real quick
animal animal
and we're going to say
the
pointer to implementation is equal
standard make
unique
of type
temple
and pass it nothing
and there we go that should take care of
the definition
of a default constructed do we have any
other constructors that we might use we
might use this one we'll worry about
that one in a second let's just go one
at a time
okay so let's work out these functions
so it can eat some calories very good so
how does it do that you gotta fill out
this truck basically
and so what we're gonna do here
is we're gonna take that implementation
and we're going to say fullness
plus equals calories
and now we're adding calories to the
fullness
and to get the fullness it's very
similar you just return
that data but you got to go through this
pointer like we talked about earlier
and there we go
do a little formatting
looks good
okay so maybe we want some checks in
here
and
naturally we probably do
so
like how many calories can you eat can
you just eat them endlessly
i don't know
probably not
but we probably have a cat
so
let's just give it a hard cap of like a
hundred
and we can do that anywhere we want we
can have a const somewhere in this class
that does that
i like the idea of having a
static const there might be a better way
to do this
but that way
um yeah it's gonna only make one
variable of this no matter how many
animals you have
and we'll say max fullness
and we'll just say it's a hundred
okay that should be okay it might not
like being initialized there
but we can say
okay so if you add the calories to it
very good then we'll say if
the fullness
is greater than max fullness
well that's not legal so then we're just
going to set it back to that
so if you try to over fill yourself it's
just going to
cap out basically
and if you want to improve this code it
is going to be on github link below
you're welcome to work on it and make a
pull request
all right that should be good we need to
make
these constructors and destructors
so we'll go ahead and do that right
about here
and of course we want to put
this uh
in front of them
and now we don't need to really do
anything too special here so we're just
going to say equals default
but they do need to be defined
there we go that should take care of
those
so that makes those pretty easy
and let's see what else here
that's a decent starting point let's go
ahead and do a few
just quick examples here and our main
so let's instantiate a new animal
uh whatever that is animal
and we will call it uh a cat
because why not
we'll say cat
dot eat
and we'll give it a
a 10
and then we'll just say
the fullness
and maybe we'll do a before and after
so standard see out
cat fullness before
eating
and here we go cat
get fullness in line
and then we'll just do the same thing
here except it's after
and now we should have two lines
and that should work
so let's go back to our linux command
line here
[Music]
and
let's go cmake um let's make a build
folder make their build
and then
we can see make
a capital b for build folder
delta build there tell the source
capital dash s
is in this current folder
there we go looks like it built okay
now we can change directory into our
build
and do an ls and we'll see that there is
a make file
now we want to actually
well that's uh that's configure i said
build but really it's configured
now we
just run this make file to build our
software
it looks like
max fullness doesn't have a type
massive oversight on our part
[Music]
if you caught that before i did congrats
but basically we just want this to be an
editor that'll be fine
all right back to the linux command line
and since we didn't change any files we
don't need to uh rerun cmake we can just
run make again
looks like it doesn't know what c out is
that's because
we didn't include ios
so that should take care of that
let's do another clear
and a make
and it looks like we forgot to put a
semicolon after a class definition
so that should be right here
very good
[Music]
and we can run make one more time
and it's complaining about something
invalid use of destructor animal as type
oh
yes we put that little dashi in the
wrong spot on there
it should be over here
because that's how it works
that's run make again
still has one more complaint point names
the constructor not the type
i gotta look at that one i don't know
what the problem is there
names the constructor not the type
uh yes okay so um
it needs a return type
here and that's the return type
and the scope thing goes here
so just doing that correctly would help
um
yeah
i don't know if i need to explain that
further
all right so now let's try it there we
go we got a successful build and we
should be able to run it let's do
another ls and there's our
program so let's just run it with the
dot slash pimp
captain fullness before eating 10 after
reading 20.
so as you can see it is working
and it is filling out that
implementation
and updating that fullness through these
functions
okay so now let's look at look at using
the move constructor and the move equals
operator
and see if we can get those to work
properly in an example
well let me just show you some some
failed cases here
and
some errors you could run into if you're
doing this with a mood constructor so
say we make another animal and we'll
just call it another cat
we're going to set other cat
equal
to the previous one
yeah that'll be fine
let's go ahead and uh clearly clear this
up a little bit
so this
is gonna try to
copy because that's what this does by
default
it's just a copy so let's see what
happens
here and you can see i've already tested
it a little bit
it'll say use of deleted function
const animal
by reference
and so yeah it is because
we deleted
this this here this copy equals operator
and it's going to be essentially the
same
if we try to construct it from another
cat
it will do the same thing
might give a different wording of the
error
but yeah use of deleted function
and
so what we actually have to do is put
standard move in front of this
and that should work that should compile
now let's go ahead and try to compile
that
clear first
and it compiles
but uh let's see if it runs it runs fine
but something very critical happened
that is not really shown in this that
will cause you problems down the road
when you move
this old one you release control of it
the day it's essentially gone
so if we try to like see out the old cat
again here like this or with any of its
functions
that's the original
cat it's the data is not going to be
there anymore
so
calling to this is going to cause a
problem
all right save that let's recompile and
take a look make
compile's fine but when we run it
we get a segfault
the reason it's seg folding is because
when we call this
the implementation is no longer there
this here what we made unique
has been moved to the other cat
and this one no longer has one
so yeah that's you got to watch out for
stuff like that because your compiler
isn't going to find that but we could
say other cat
and it's going to have those
implementation details
and this will be okay
but the problem
here is
well this previous cat
it's gonna
the the implementation's still gonna sit
there or not the implementation
the interface is still gonna sit in
memory
so you gotta think about stuff like that
if you're passing this off via a move
then you want to be sure to de-allocate
the old one
and the easiest way to do that might be
to use
something like a pointer instead
uh let me just go ahead and run this
with the other cat get fullness just to
show you
it should also keep
the fullness
so it should have
uh 20 yeah there we go
maybe i'll say other here
yeah
all right so what what can we do instead
since we don't want to accidentally
have this one floating around without
its implementation anymore since we
moved it
well basically
kind of testing this out see how it
works
you can do this instead you can say
equals new
[Music]
animal
so now it's a pointer
and we have a little bit more control
over it like the way to get rid of the
non-pointer one is to basically have it
go out of scope
but the way to get rid of this one is
well we can call our memory management
functions
on it to get rid of it
so
these are all going to now be
pointers
pointer
the reference there
but now when we move this
we need to dereference
and
that might work let's give it a try
yeah it worked
let's try it there
looks fine
so what we want to do here
is after we finish moving it
we can delete the old cap so we can call
delete
cat
that's the original one and then we can
also set it to null pointer
and that way we can't accidentally
well it's just more obvious now
that it's no longer viable data
so what happens if we try to call a
function on this
old cat
well we should
get some error of some sort
let's see what we get here
compiler doesn't detect it
still get a segmentation fault
because it's no longer there
now this move
now to be honest
i'm getting it a little in over my head
at this point and probably making this
more confusing
but just know that once you move it the
old one's gone you can't use it anymore
unless you reallocate it
because
as you can see we've we've done all this
and we tried to get fullness again
but what you actually want to do is you
want to do a null check if
uh
and you can just do it like this
if it exists
so you're probably going to have you
know code bouncing around between
functions doing special stuff it's not
necessarily going to be a nice
straight down the line thing like you're
seeing here
so you want to do these null checks
basically
so let's do this
clear and we'll just run it
and you can see it doesn't even call the
second one
because this fails and skips over it
so
what we can do instead if you want you
could
you could reallocate a new one or
something like that there are options
here
so if not cat
uh we'll say cat equals new animal once
again
and then we should be able to get the
fullness again
and run it
and there's the cat nice and reset
okay
well
uh i don't want to make this any more
confusing that i've probably made it to
this point
so
that's kind of the crux
of this pointer to the implementation
there's a whole lot more you can do but
hopefully this makes sense the main
thing here is that these implementation
details are fully private
and this is more of just an interface
so
if you just imp if you just update
this implementation here
anything that is using your animal class
is not necessarily going to need to
recompile
so it works pretty decently for
interfaces a lot of times and just one
last thing i want to show here that was
mentioned in some of those documents
is sometimes you want this
implementation to be able to talk back
to this actual public interface
so you might have let's say for example
a function that's like
boolean
uh
and
let's say that
i can spell
that looks like one word okay
so you want to know if it can eat or not
that's uh
basically all this function is going to
do so let's go ahead and define it
and it is going to be defined outside
this implementation because it is just
part of the animal
now this is just a naive example
like you might even want this as part of
the implementation in reality but for
for the case for the sake of example
is a bad example
let's say
let's say something else like
maybe we don't want in the
implementation whether it's dead or
alive maybe that's like
something that's a little more public so
we'll say is a lot
that's
that's pretty standard uh
a pretty common function to have
so he's alive and we're just going to
return through all the time
for now we'll just say it's always alive
no dead cats around here we're not that
close to halloween
okay so the point here is
maybe you want to check
if it's uh alive before d
so instead of calling
well instead of this uh
let's see this heat command
just calling this directly
maybe
maybe it calls another function and we
have publicly an animal here called
um animal
well well let's see here
we'll say void
okay we'll just remake the function here
basically
boy eat and
calories
and we'll define the function right here
and we'll essentially do the same thing
except we don't need to make this call
all the time
uh this because we have access to that
member right there
so we can get rid of all these
pimple dereferences
all right let's indent that properly so
it can actually be red
and
well the problem here
is we're not going to have access to max
fullness well we can access it
by going something like this
so that'll be fine
but that might be getting a little wonky
i don't know if that'll even compile
but okay the point is now we can delete
all this
and we can just call the implementation
of eat
and pass it those calories
however
what if we want to check if it's alive
here
uh effective cat is alive first
well that function is part of animal as
well it's not static so we can't just
get to it like so
with this max fullness thing
so what we have to do
is in this call here
we want to pass it a reference
uh back to itself back to the interface
so
we will be passing it star this
and then this function up here
it's to take
animal
uh and we need a name here i'll just
call it a
and then we can check
if it's alive
by going a
is alive
and then we do the whole thing
put some brackets around this so it
works
add this over
and let's see if that works
now of course is alive it's just always
going to be true but we just want to see
that it still works as we expect so
let's run make again
and we get some errors
calories was not oh i renamed this
so it's just cal let's uh
let's give it the full name here
that'll be a little easier to work with
clear
make
oh is a live as a function
so we need to call it like a function
very good
all right clear we're going to make
cannot convert animal to animal star
okay all right so this needs to
basically we want it to be a const
animal
reference
because this is going to
uh reference the class basically i think
that's right
so let's call make again
uh it's a non-pointer type it says
okay so let's do that
let's try that
uh passing const discards quantifier
okay so that's maybe where we want the
the cons
thing to be a little more
there are the propagate costs that's
probably where the propagate cost comes
in
it looks like it doesn't know what oh
we're doing this in caps for some reason
we don't want to do that
okay so just cleaning up a few basic
errors and there we go we get it
work
and it works correctly
and
yeah so that's how
you pass your implementation
the front end
so it can call any of its public
functions like this is alive or whatever
you may have
and there we go but now they are coupled
together both ways and
it's a it's a little different but it
can be done and that's how you do it
and it's uh that's all i wanted to show
there it's just basically forwarding it
along with the interface
like so because that is often done
if you want to check something before
you continue
like whether it's shown or hidden or
whether it's alive or something like
that well that's pretty much it for this
episode
thank you all for watching special shout
out to my patrons for making episodes
like these possible
we do have some new funding goals up
hopefully we can meet them to keep all
these videos continuing i really
appreciate you guys and we'll see you
next episode peace out
up
[Music]
up
[Music]
up
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you